NICK BUTCHER: Hello, and
welcome back to ADIA.
It's been a little
while since we've
been giving you design
in action advice.
But we're back today to talk to
you about the Google I/O 2014
conference app and
how we designed it.
So as always, I'm your
host, Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Hey, guys.
I'm Roman Nurik, dialing
in here from New York
in our fancy new space
on the 11th floor here.
And also, in this weird
looking, weird evil doctor
laboratory type environment.
So yeah, hi, guys.
MIKE DENNY: And hey, guys.
I'm Mike Denny from Mountain
View in a phone room.
People will be walking by.
NICK BUTCHER: So as I
said, this week, we're
talking about the
Google I/O application.
So for anyone who
doesn't know, Google I/O
is our annual
developer conference.
But well, for more than
the developers this year.
There was a huge focus on
design content as well.
And each year, to
accompany the conference,
we put out a companion
Android application,
which helps you to
find the sessions,
create a personalized
schedule, navigate around
the conference, and
lots, lots more.
But that's almost secondary
to its almost main goal, which
is to be an open source
application, to share
the code and best practices
with a bunch of developers
out there.
And we'd like to really
do the same kind of thing
and give a peek
behind the curtain
into the design process.
So the I/O app is
built by our team,
and Roman, Mike, and myself were
three of the designers working
on the application in
close collaboration
with the core material design
team right here at Google.
So we want to take this
opportunity to give you,
like I say, a peek behind
the curtain of how we went
about designing the
app and giving you
some advice of problems
we ran into and processes
we found to work really well.
OK, so without further ado,
let's jump into the content.
So when we came to wanting
to update the application,
as always, the first place we
started was with sketching.
And there were a
few things we wanted
to do with the
application this year.
First off, there was an
updated information model
we were trying to work
into the application.
There were some big changes.
We're going to be pushing
to get more imagery
into the application to
really bring it to life.
And that was finally
arriving this year,
so there was a lot we
wanted to do with imagery.
And lastly, always
most exciting,
we wanted to introduce some of
the elements of material design
into the application.
So we have a challenge.
And this application
was obviously
shipping to existing
versions of Android
out there without new
APIs and new support
for all this crazy stuff
like real time shadows.
So we had to do a
conservative approach
of what we could use
on earlier devices
as well as on newer devices
which got the L preview.
We wanted to really show off
some of the great new design
features.
So like many of
you, we'd seen lots
of the exciting output of
the material design team.
They'd shown lots of great
explorations and videos
showcasing their
new design system
and what it could produce.
And we naturally wanted to dive
in and reproduce some of this.
So our first instinct was to
rush straight to visual design
and put together
some mockups of how
we could apply the material
design principles to the I/O
application.
But as you can see from these,
some early explorations we're
sharing with you here, these
weren't quite satisfying.
It wasn't quite hitting
the right notes.
And what's more, the work
that we were producing
felt somewhat disjointed.
And this is a real
trap you can fall in,
the temptation to rush
straight to pixels.
So what we actually did was
to take a step back and really
work out our information
models and our flows
before going to do the
visual design stage.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, so
what we ended up doing
is dropping down a step to what
we're calling white frames,
if you look in the
Google design spec.
You can download a lot of
Adobe Illustrator files
that give a bunch of blank
templatey feeling screens that
are not quite-- a little
bit more than wireframes,
but a little bit less than
a visual design mock up.
And so in that kind
of intermediary step,
it allowed us to really
explore the challenges
that the update to
the app proposed.
And the most difficult
thing, I think,
for us was to figure out how
to most simply show and allow
for filtration and selection,
the collections of all
the different sessions
and sandbox events,
and all the different things
you could do at the conference.
We also had to think about
two different groups of users.
About 5,000 people at Moscone
West in the conference hall
would be using the app.
And they'll be making
use of the indoor map
to find which room they need to
go to watch a certain session.
But the vast
majority of our users
are people at home or
at I/O Extended Events
who weren't able to attend
in person in San Francisco.
So we wanted to really make a
great app experience for them,
as well.
The interesting change in 2014
from previous years at Google
I/O was that each
session, instead
of being part of a track
around a specific product,
like the Android
sessions, or the Glass
sessions, or the Chrome
sessions, this year
the conference was separated
around functional roles,
or what we ended
up calling themes.
And those were design,
develop, and distribute.
So you had those three
broad categories,
those themes that gave structure
to the sessions themselves.
But we also, of course, had
product specific topic tags
and business vertical tags
like commerce, retail.
We had music, media,
games, Android, of course,
Chrome, Go, all these
different-- just tons of ways
to dissect and
create cross-sections
of this huge jumble of
sessions and other content.
And it really took a lot
of time and collaboration
and arguing back and forth,
should this be a list?
Should this be a grid?
Can it be a list on phones
and a grid on tablets?
How do we do the filtration?
Do you jump in and pick a track,
say show me only Android stuff?
Or can you be a little bit
more fine grained than that?
Where's the line
of filtering down
to really present the
amount of information
that the user is looking for?
So it definitely helped
us to take a step back
into the wireframe,
the white frame stage,
and look more structurally
at the interactions
of the different screens
and how the users were
going to be moving
throughout the app
and through the
different stages.
NICK BUTCHER: Just one quick
note on the white frames,
we've put a little
link in the corner
here to download these
Adobe Illustrator files.
But there's also some
community members
that really already
stepped up and produced
Sketch versions of these.
So if you're
getting into Sketch,
which I have been
enjoying a lot lately,
I can add a link in the show
notes to find that, as well.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, so to
help facilitate the fact
that three designers
working across three time
zones on this
really complex app,
we ended up just
using Google Slides
and drawing out shapes
in really rough ways,
because it allowed us to
make comments directly
on specific areas
and have a discussion
in an asynchronous way.
ROMAN NURIK: I want to
add something on that.
I think that's really,
really critical.
Something I always talk
about in development
is your iteration loop,
how fast you can iterate.
And I feel like
there are great tools
for iterating in development.
You make a change to
some code, you push it,
and it shows up on your phone.
On the web, it's even faster.
You make a change, and
you refresh the page.
Here, when you do
design work, design
is an inherently
collaborative thing.
Design is a conversation.
It's a conversation between
various people working
on a product.
And so I feel like the
integration loop here
was critical.
To be able to build out these
new features pretty quickly,
we really needed to be
able to have three people,
again, across three
different time zones working
on one thing in a
single, shared space.
Mike would put
together a screen.
I would make a quick comment.
I would select the item
in Google Slides, the box
or whatever it was,
make a comment on it.
Mike would make some tweaks.
Later on, I'd just push
something down a few pixels
so that there was some alignment
across different slides.
But the overall environment
for Google Drive,
basically using Google Slides
to collaborate on wireframes,
worked out really well for us.
Obviously, it's super,
super low fidelity.
But just to get
the point across,
the information on the screen,
the general macro level layout
was super useful.
NICK BUTCHER: And
I feel like forcing
us to work in low
fidelity really helped us
to focus the conversation
on the zoomed out,
rather than getting bogged down
in the minutia of the pixels.
It helped us to think
about the larger problems,
like how are we going
to do filtering?
How are we going to
display collections?
Rather than getting too
bogged down too early.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, definitely.
It's super interesting
to go back and look
at that slides deck because
everything at the bottom
is like slide purgatory,
all of our rejected ideas.
Old slides, we just dragged
them to the bottom of the stack
and forget about them forever.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, what
it could have been!
So after we really had worked
a lot on the wireframes,
we wanted to step
up and introduce
a lot of the material
design elements
that we were hugely
excited about working
into the application.
So we're going to go through
now some of our interpretations
of what we felt
was most critical
and how we interpreted
them into the application.
This isn't going to
be like a thou shalt,
this is the only way you
can apply material design
to your application.
In fact, we were actually
kind of working on this
while the material design
spec was somewhat in flux
and changing a little
bit, as these things
are wont to do before
they get launched.
So if some things we did don't
quite work for your application
or have evolved since
then, that's fine.
This is part of the
evolving design process.
But some of the key things that
we definitely wanted to use
was the key lines
and layout metrics
which material
design introduced.
The idea of using these
print style layouts-- Roman,
do you want to talk
about the key lines some?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, yeah.
Well, the first thing
is that the key lines
are kind of like a
hallmark or a signature
characteristic of a
material design app.
When you see some of that text,
some of the body copy aligned
to that 72-bit key line,
that second key line,
it is very much a signature
aspects of material design.
It evokes material design, the
personality of the framework.
And another thing I
just wanted to mention
is that when I first saw this,
I was like, this looks great.
This makes a lot of sense,
too, gestalt principles.
When things are aligned,
they kind of naturally group
together so you can
understand that these
are part of a
single, whole thing.
It also makes it
much easier to scan.
Your eyes don't have
to bounce around
between different starting
points [INAUDIBLE].
But besides that, it
kind of reminds me,
one of the things
that I allude to when
I talk about this with
folks is this kind
of reminds me of textbooks.
When you look at print
design, print and designing
for magazines or textbooks
and things like that,
you kind of have your
primary columns--
and I'm probably using
all the wrong language
here because I'm not
a print designer.
You have your primary
body copy columns.
And then, you have
stuff on the outside.
Imagine a textbook, right?
You have your primary
prose in the middle.
And then, you have little asides
or other accompanying items
along the sides in the
gutters in those margins.
And so I look at this
as these key lines
help establish
that middle column.
And then, you have things
on the outsides like the Add
to Schedule floating
action button here.
Or when you're looking
at speaker details,
the speaker avatars, the
photos of the speakers,
are in those margins.
So I kind of look
at it that way.
And it does, again,
help for scanning.
It's very easy to, once you
lay that one piece of text
on the screen, just look all
the way down and very quickly
scan the rest of
the text related
to that first piece of text.
In this case, the title,
description, and so on,
and the metadata as
well for the session.
NICK BUTCHER: And
another thing I really
liked about using the key
lines in our design process,
it was a very easy way to
bake in some responsive design
principles into layouts.
So in these screenshots here,
you can see, for example,
we've called out what
the key lines should
be on a smaller device.
But then, you can
very easily just
increase these key
lines on larger devices
and build in this
kind of responsiveness
from upfront
thinking about where
the different
blocks of text are.
You're designing
the use of content
and the use of white
space deliberately.
And then, you can then
vary those amounts,
the way they scale up as you
have more space on a device.
ROMAN NURIK: The other thing
I wanted to mention here,
and yeah, that
totally makes sense
to me, the responsive nature,
we bump things up on tablets,
right?
But if you look at the actual
numbers, 16 and 24, 72 and 80,
one thing we haven't
really mentioned is grids.
And this has been around
on Android for a while
using a 4 DIP or an 8 DIP grid.
In this case, everything
in material design,
all the suggested values,
they fall on that grid.
It makes it really
easy to I guess
diverge from the guidelines
when you feel it's necessary,
when you need to.
So these 16 DIPs,
the 72 DIPs, these
are just suggested guidelines.
But if you need a bit more
space in that left margin,
it's really easy to say,
let me try to add 8 DIPs.
Let me try to add 16
DIPs to that key line
and see if that kind of
better communicates my content
or gives my content more space
to breathe or whatever it is.
And so I kind of look
at material design
and these key lines specifically
as they're suggestions.
But there's, at the lower
level parts of the framework,
this grid system helps you
deviate from those suggestions
very easily and in
a very standard way.
So that's one of the
things that I really
loved about this process.
We ended up choosing
the 80 DIP key line.
But we could have done
96 or 104 on tablets
if we felt it was necessary.
So let's talk about
surfaces for a bit.
And this is actually one of
the biggest components actually
looking at material design as
composed of four basic things.
Surfaces and shadows are one
of the biggest things to me.
And actually, there's a
design byte either out now
or coming out from
Rich Fulcher where
he talks about specifically
surfaces and shadows
and how those effect the
universe, if you will,
of apps following
this framework.
And for surfaces,
he kind of alludes
to surfaces as pieces of paper.
And when a surface is
floating over another surface
in the z space, it casts a
shadow on the surface below it
or the piece of paper below it.
And so we thought
a lot about this
because this is one of the key
components of material design.
We thought a lot about this.
And so that influenced
some of our decisions.
NICK BUTCHER: So one technique
which we've not shown here
in our mocks is ways to,
in your design stage,
show which level on the z access
a particular surface lives.
So we didn't use it at the
time of designing the I/O app.
I've been using it in
my design since then.
It's actually a call out,
so when you're specing up
a screen, as well as when you're
calling out the color or size
or shape, whatever,
it's to say that this
lives in a particular plane.
So the way we've
been doing that is it
helps to think about it in--
if you might have, say, three,
four, maybe five
different z levels,
you can call it z0, z1,
z2, z3, and call those
out so that you can then use
those levels consistently
throughout your application.
So you might say that,
in your application,
in the primary
content, there's a z0.
Whereas in this example
here, the bottom bar,
the bottom section
lives at z level one
and the floating
action button is
on top of that at z level two.
And then, what
you can then do is
when you hand that
over to developers,
is decide what levels,
what dimensions and DIPs
those levels of z work at.
And then, transfer those
into actual dimensions.
It's kind of like thinking
about an air traffic
controller, where you're
thinking each of your UI
surfaces is actually a different
plane, a different level.
So you're trying to work out how
they stack on top of each other
without colliding so they can
move underneath each other
and give you that natural motion
you're trying to design for.
ROMAN NURIK: So one of the
things that we came across,
one of the decisions we had to
make was how we present tabs.
And specifically, we have this
case in the schedule screen
where you have an
app bar at the top,
and you have tabs for
today or tomorrow,
or June 25 and June
26, and then you
have content below
that, basically
the schedule for
each day below that.
And there are obviously a number
of ways you can present that.
And the final decision
that we made here
had a lot to do with how
surfaces are described
and presented in
material design.
And so in our first
iteration, we kind of
had these two surfaces,
one for the app bar
and a second just for the
tabs and the content below it.
One of the interesting
things here
is that, well first
of all, there's
a lot of ink on these
surfaces, the stuff that's
printed on the piece of paper
or printed on the surface.
There was a lot of
ink here, and we
felt like it was
doing a lot of work.
NICK BUTCHER: For me,
this feels kind of funky
because the second, the angled
screen shot, the content
will scroll underneath
the tab, right?
If you scroll the surface,
breakfast, it'll go under it.
So you're almost making
another seam at that point
because you're
expecting it to split
into another middle surface,
while the app bar itself casts
a shadow while you look at it.
So it's like you have
three surfaces almost.
ROMAN NURIK: At the same time,
an even more important point,
as Nick pointed out
earlier, was that
what happens when the
other content scrolls?
What happens when you scroll
the schedule up and down?
It'd be weird if
the ink scrolled
along the surface,
and the surface
itself didn't just move.
It's a much more natural
thing for a surface
to slide up and down than for
ink to slide along a surface.
It's a weird way
of explaining it,
but it's how we perceived it.
And so in this case where
there's a single surface where
the tabs and the tab
contents were printed
along the same surface, it
didn't really make sense to us.
And so we moved it on
to the second iteration
where we actually merged
the tabs with the app bar.
This also better
followed the spec anyway,
so it was kind of a win-win.
But here, a lot of things
worked out really well here.
First of all, all
the, quote unquote,
"chrome" became part of one
physical entity, one surface.
And all the actual content
was on a surface below it.
And so it also
solved the problem
where as you start
scrolling the content,
it slides underneath
all of the chrome.
It also was a much simpler
visual presentation.
It was just, in
general, cleaner.
So that's why we
went with this route.
NICK BUTCHER: The next
element of material design
that we definitely went
into to utilize was motion.
So I'd say we didn't have enough
time to work on as much motion
as we'd like, but
some areas, we did
craft some kind of key
details which I feel really
do add to bringing life
to the application.
So one of Roman's
favorite, which
he uses multiple times
a day, was the use
of the floating action button.
ROMAN NURIK: So yeah, the
floating action button
is probably one of
my favorite elements
not just because the floating
action button itself,
especially when it straddles
the seam between two surfaces,
not only because it's
just so characteristic,
it's such a signature
element of material design,
but also because there's
so much you can do with it.
It's such an expressive element.
So in our case, we had
this floating action button
that when you press it on
the session detail screen,
when you press it, it adds
the session to your schedule
and it goes from a plus
sign to a check mark.
And when you press
the check mark,
it goes back into a plus sign.
And so there's a couple of
interesting tidbits here.
It's a floating action
button that has two states.
It has to have an on
state and an off state.
And also, this is a
case where there's
a transition between
the two icons,
between a plus and a check mark.
And in material design,
basically any time
you have an icon
with multiple states,
for example a refresh button
that turns into a loading
spinner, or a plus that
turns into a check mark,
or something like that,
that's a great opportunity
for a delightful animation.
And so we used this
opportunity to introduce
some kind of character
into our app.
We also used this
opportunity to transition
the state of the background
coloring from blue to white,
which we'll talk about in a bit.
We used that opportunity
to actually make
that transition, a background
color, even more interesting,
to also kind of use stuff
from material design
to make it feel like, as a user,
you're pressing on this button,
and the background
color is changing right
under your fingertip.
It's like you're initiating
this change of background color.
And this kind of ripple
effect that we use
helps show that, helps
demonstrate that.
NICK BUTCHER: I
love the idea of you
as a user imparting energy into
the interface that radiates out
from your touch point.
It makes you feel very
much like you're in control
and you're very powerful,
which is kind of cool.
So another place where
we used this kind
of the same animated
touch feedback
is the use of the
ripples in order
to communicate touch
states as well as to have
that same kind of feeling
like the user is in control.
So you can see here that we used
some customized touch ripples
in both the bounded and
unbounded states, which
you can see in this video,
to give that sense of control
to the user.
As I alluded earlier,
we ran out of time
with implementing
everything that we
wanted to do in
this year's update.
But one thing
which is definitely
on the books for the
next time we look at it
is to add some more motion
to the major scene changes.
Material design definitely
talks about helping
to give the users more
consistency by explaining scene
changes rather than doing a
jump cut, as you might call it.
So one place which we
felt was a natural fit
for this was when jumping
from a collection view,
kind of like the
home screen, which
shows a whole group
of different sessions,
into one of the
session's details.
We felt this would be
like a natural place
where we could nicely
animate up the image,
maybe move the title inline,
ease that transition,
keep the user in
the sense of things
rather than doing this jump cut.
So maybe next year,
we'll get to that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and another
thing we had to think about
is for these hero
transitions, obviously there's
a place in our app where
it makes a lot of sense.
When you're exploring
a list of sessions
or that grid of
sessions, after you've
chosen some filters and so on,
when you press a grid tile,
it can expand up and show
the session detail screen.
So the image in
the grid tile can
expand into the banner
image for the detail screen.
The only issue
with that, though,
is we had a lot of overlays.
We had color overlays
in some cases.
We had text overlays.
And we really had to think
hard about how exactly each
of these elements transitions.
And like Nick said, we
just didn't have the time
to really solidify this, to
really play around with it
and get it just right.
And so we decided basically
to take a shortcut
and just use the standard
non-hero transitions,
but definitely something we
want to look for in the future,
and definitely something
that, for simpler cases, where
you have just a grid
of basic images,
it makes the most
sense to include
these types of hero transitions.
NICK BUTCHER: Next
up, we're going
to talk about our use of
color in the application,
and here with the correct
spelling of the word "color."
So these are some
early explorations
we threw together,
really playing around
with different layers,
the different treatments
for images.
As Mike mentioned earlier, we
had a lot of different ways
to organize the items
and [INAUDIBLE] model.
So a particular session
could belong to both a track,
like Android, as
well as a theme,
like design, or
develop, or distribute.
So we were trying to play with
ways that we could represent
that to the user so
they could navigate
between related sessions
as well as recognize
a schedule from a glance.
So here's some
early explorations
where we were trying
different color
overlays, different colored
action bars, and so forth.
And at the same time, we
were working-- obviously,
this Android app doesn't
live in isolation.
We were working with
the team building
the website and the rest of
the branding for their site
on the overall color palette.
Do you want to talk about
how that developed, Roman?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so in
terms of the color palette,
definitely know
that the I/O team--
we started working on this right
around the time the I/O core
team was working
with their folks
to figure out what the
overall brand is, kind
of evolving the
brand from last year.
And they're definitely
including or incorporating
material design
elements early on.
And so their first set of
core colors, or actually I
guess the final
set of core colors,
were taken straight out of the
secondary material design color
palette.
So they chose beautiful
colors actually, like indigo,
pink, the light blue.
And we actually found
that this works really
well in the context of the app
where the indigo 500 served
to be the primary action
bar color in cases where
the current screen
is not branded,
or doesn't have a color
associated with it, a session
color.
And then, we used the light
blue and pink versions
as accent colors.
And so I actually talk about
this a bit more in the design
byte on the IO app
and material design.
But it worked really, really
well in the context of our app
and the context of
material design,
where basically you want a
slightly more muted yet still
colorful primary color, and then
a very strong, very bold accent
color.
And we chose two accent colors
for different situations.
NICK BUTCHER: I think this is
an interesting point, actually.
Even though the
material guidelines
come with a set
of color palettes
which you can use
in your application,
it really isn't prescriptive.
You should really be
using color to reflect
the brand, the personality,
of your application.
And so like here, we've
used two accent colors
rather than just using a
single accent color throughout,
because that gave us
the range we needed
to express a bunch of
different key concepts
in the application.
So really don't feel constrained
by the color guidelines.
Use them for inspiration
and learn from them.
But don't ever feel like
they're holding you back.
MIKE DENNY: Could it be that
the light blue was a reminiscent
throwback to the [INAUDIBLE]
blue of yesteryear?
ROMAN NURIK:
Potentialy, possibly.
No, probably not.
NICK BUTCHER: Just no, no-go.
No-go, Mike.
ROMAN NURIK: One other
thing I wanted to show,
or I guess talk
about really briefly,
is color is important
for-- color,
we also took it as
a piece of content.
Our sessions are colored
based on their topic.
So for example, Android
sessions are green.
We tried to make this make
as much sense as possible.
Sometimes, you have
pretty vague or there
aren't natural mappings
for certain topics,
like for example, UX.
How do you color the word
UX, or the concept UX?
NICK BUTCHER: We actually
tried to be [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Plaid-patterned,
that's right.
So we tried to make it make
sense as much as possible.
But we ran into a
lot of situations
where we really needed to
make some tough decisions on,
do we use the session
color here or not?
Because of all the other
components of the app,
for example, the
floating action button,
we had to make
some tough choices
as to how and when
we incorporate color.
NICK BUTCHER: And staying
on the topic of color,
I went into a deep
dive on a little piece
of the work we did when we
were thinking about using
these different colors per
session to reflect its topic
or track or so forth.
And we were really investigating
how to then contrast
that with the featured action
button, floating action button.
So one of our
first instincts was
to pick an accent shade to
go with each of these theming
colors.
So you can see on this
top row of screens
here that every
single color, we're
trying to pick out something
that would represent the two
states the button had, add
to schedule and reflecting it
was in your schedule.
But in doing so, it ended
up just getting too noisy.
It ended up being, this
is a really key action
that we want to call out.
But it'll end up
looking different
on a bunch of different
screens you're going into
and just not really working.
And also, it caused us a
lot of work to think about,
is this button going
to do the same thing?
And so forth.
So then, we started trying
to find single colors that
would work across all of them,
which started off being quite
hard, but we ended up going with
a white FAB for sessions which
were already in your schedule,
and this hot blue FAB
for sessions which
weren't, which ended up
contrasting really
well with our palette.
ROMAN NURIK: And
this is something
that we talked about
before, where we also
had a really nice
way of transitioning
between these states
where, when you press
the blue plus or the plus
sign on a blue background,
there's this little
white ripple.
The background changes
to white in a ripple,
and it kind of fills
the space, almost
like a paint bucket
effect in Photoshop.
And so on we were deciding
how and when to use color.
And as Nick pointed out,
the FAB, the floating action
button, played a
big role in that.
And so one of the tools
that we used here,
to decide actually which colors
to use for sessions which
had a brand, quote
unquote, for each session,
We actually used this
little exploration
file where we started with the
material design color palette.
We threw those colors
into these square blocks.
And we used the accent, our
light blue accent color FAB,
and we just dropped that
in adjacent to all these
items just to see what the
juxtaposition looked like.
Was there enough contrast?
Were there color clashes, things
that just didn't look right?
And so we used this
kind of temporary file
to start messing with
those color values
to make sure that
they contrasted well.
At the same time, we
also wanted to make sure
that all these session
colors contrasted well
with each other.
Actually, not necessarily
contrasted well,
but they weren't too different.
When you looked at one session
detail page versus another,
there weren't glaring
brightness differences.
So one of the ways
we did that, kind
of stabilize the
overall kind of contrast
profile of our screens, was that
we took this exploration file
and desaturated it, and then
we made a bunch of changes
here and there to
these color values
to make sure that the actual
brightness, overall brightness,
of the session colors was
within an acceptable, well
defined range, that we didn't
have anything that was way
too bright or anything
that was way too dark.
And so that was one of the ways
in which we ensured that this
would be both usable,
would be legible,
but also would just
look good overall.
NICK BUTCHER: I think the last
step we went through, then,
was then this example
of the specing work
that we did in order to document
the layout sizes and so on.
One thing I very much
enjoyed about using this
was referring to the
material typographic scale.
I found that by utilizing
the typographic scale,
using things like you
can see on the left here,
when you're setting the
title of the session details
page, the title scale, it
really gave a great structure
to the application.
I hope that as more and
more applications converge
on this material
typographic scale
and then deviate when
needed, it will really
help with the
scalability of the app.
You'll be able to instantly
pick out, oh, that's the title,
I recognize.
At some subconscious level,
I recognize the way it's set,
that it's [INAUDIBLE] for
example, that's a title,
and I can scan that.
I can jump to that
on the screen.
So I find that I
really enjoy working
with the typographic scale.
MIKE DENNY: In general, we've
been talking about material
spec and material
guidelines and how we feel
they're not as
prescriptive as before.
Hollow had a very
distinct personality.
In the same vein,
material does, as well.
And Google's products
expressing themselves
using material design system
will feel very Googley.
And you, and all of
your apps, should
be able to express their own
brands using similar elements,
like sticking to the 4 or 8 DIP
grid using primary key lines.
Even if you deviate
in meaningful ways,
it'll still feel at home on
Android devices and on the web.
In addition to that,
the typographic scale
that Nick was just
talking about,
if you don't use
the material spec
recommended typographic
scale, create your own.
Don't have a million
different font
sizes and weights
and attributes.
Be consistent and be
purposeful in your deviations
from the spec.
ROMAN NURIK: I guess
one thing to add
there is while we're on
the topic of typography,
a big part of your
brand is typography.
And so in material design,
we talk a lot about Roboto
and we have very specific styles
for headline text and body
text, and they're all
basically using Roboto.
It doesn't mean that
Roboto is the only way
to design an Android app.
A lot of great, really well
designed Android apps today
use different typefaces.
And material design is the same.
You don't necessarily
have to use Roboto.
You should probably
use pretty good
looking sans serif typefaces.
You probably should avoid using
too many serifs in your apps.
But it's definitely
something where
that is an area where you
should be true to your brand.
You shouldn't try to force your
brand into Roboto unless you
feel like it is harmonious
with your brand.
So yeah, that's just another
thing that we thought about.
Obviously, Roboto makes a lot
of sense for Google products.
But a lot of other
apps, it's not
a necessity you have to use it.
We think it looks great, though.
One other thing I guess
on the concept of type,
and I guess we may have talked
about some previous [INAUDIBLE]
or maybe not, but when
you do choose a typeface,
it's important to test
it on Android devices.
Some typefaces just
don't render too well.
There's all sorts
of weird hinting
and weird stuff that happens,
especially at smaller sizes.
So just do make sure to test.
And if you do test and
you find that there's
some rendering issues, then try
to work with the original type
foundry or whatever, see if
they have a more optimized type
face for different use cases.
In a lot of cases,
there's different variants
of a type face for use
in different situations,
some print design, some for
UI design, things like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Wow, so thank you.
That was a whistle stop
tour of the updated design
of the Google I/O application.
There's tons more
features in there
which we didn't get to cover.
So do go and check
out the application.
Download the L preview version.
We'll put a link to it
in the bottom notes here.
And take a look at
some of these features.
We didn't even cover
designing for wearables
and other such features.
So there's lots in
there to go check out.
So finish up.
Let's just talk about
our one favorite feature
of designing the Google I/O app.
I'll go first, and I'll say that
my absolute favorite thing was
working with the baseline
grids and the key lines.
I felt that gave you really,
really great structure
to the application,
which was really
kind of a joy to work with.
Mike?
MIKE DENNY: I really
ended up liking
the way we presented the
schedule in columns based
on the two days
of the conference.
Previous years at Google had
been three days or two days.
This year, it was
two days, and we
were able to present
that in swipeable tabs
on smaller screens, and
then just straight up
two columns on larger screens.
And it ended up being a
really nice experience
to be very glanceable while
I was at the conference.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I
think my favorite thing,
and before I jump
into that, I'm going
to quickly plug a couple
of things that we released,
the design byte episode,
the eight minute or nine
minute design byte on our
design process for this app.
I talk about this, and also
in a Medium post, a blog post
I posted on Medium.
I talk about this.
But one of my favorite things
is really the use of color,
specifically the primary
and the accent colors,
and the way we introduce
those into the apps.
You can't really see it in the
vignette screenshot shown here.
But it's basically awesome.
We got to use a strong
accent color, a really
bold, bright,
beautiful accent color
in a number of situations.
And on L, it's
super, super easy.
We basically said
hey, Android system,
here is the pink we want
to use for our accents.
And it just kind
of automatically
colored a lot of stuff
for us in the UI,
which was just automatically
colored based on that.
So I just really enjoyed
working with that color palette.
One of my favorite things now
is when we design new apps, just
try to pick out what's a good
combination of a slightly
muted but colorful
primary color,
and a really bright,
bold accent color.
Choosing those colors is
actually part of the fun part.
It's pretty subjective.
It's something where
you get to think
about the artistic aspects
of designing an app.
And that's just definitely
one of my favorite things
going forward, picking
out those colors.
NICK BUTCHER: So it's not
the animated floating action
button?
I was sure that was going
to be your favorite.
ROMAN NURIK: Well, that too.
But I feel like I've
talked quite at length
about how much I love that
little component of it we
put together.
MIKE DENNY: I definitely
want to call out
before we wrap up just
how key the use of imagery
and photography was
throughout the app.
This year, our
team really pushed
to have provided
for each session
a photographic representation
of the speaker or the team
presenting.
And I don't know we got 100%
coverage for every session
or event, but we
got a lot of photos.
And it definitely helped the
app feel a lot more human.
And gives a lot of
just beautiful variance
throughout the app.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I agree.
We could have gone
with just text, right?
In previous years, we just
have a text representation.
And some may argue that it's
actually easier to scan text,
just looking through
text to see key words.
But that's what
the search is for.
If you're looking for something,
search for the piece of text
you want.
But yeah, I totally agree.
The images made it
feel more human.
I love the way you explain that.
It feels like-- going to
I/O, it's all about speakers.
You're going there to
listen to people talk.
You're going there
to meet people.
And having these people's
faces in a nice, larger size
than just a little
avatar makes it
feel like you're actually going
somewhere, going to the session
to listen to that person talk.
It's a stronger connection.
So yeah, I'm really glad we
were able to get that through.
It was a tough process to
get approval and get people
to be on board with
taking all these photos.
But I'm really glad
that went through.
It was really kind of a big, big
help for the visual character
and the emotional
character of the app.
NICK BUTCHER: That was more
than one thing each, guys,
but that's OK.
OK, so thank you very much
for joining us for ADIA.
We'll be back with
more content soon.
Adios!
ROMAN NURIK: Peace out!
MIKE DENNY: Thanks.
See you.